[Music]
hi everyone thank you for attending gcp
mix and coming to our session alerting
best practices my name is Amir hermelin
and I'm a product manager on Google
cloud platform and specifically I focus
on stackdriver with me here is Thomas I
am Thomas rest I'm an SRE on one of the
three teams that runs the stacks I
Rebecca and part and we're here to talk
today about alerting best practices and
what we've learned monitoring and
learning services at scale at Google and
also helping our users monitor their
services on cloud platform a lot of the
topics we cover are included in this
book sre the site reliability
engineering handbook and will also be
giving away a couple of these signs at
the end of the session so we're sticking
around it's time by the VP of s3 which
is kind of cool so a little bit let's go
over the agenda so we'll start with a
little history on how monitoring and
alerting has evolved at Google go over
an overview and some quick definitions
just so you know we're all on the same
page and then we can dive into the
monitoring and alerting the philosophy
the why the what guides us when we do
the things we do then we'll go into best
practices and lesson learned lessons
learned and this is the more kind of
practical part of the of this session
towards the end we'll talk a little bit
about suggested processes and then we'll
wrap up with Q&A so before we start
slides are not self explanatory so if
you're just wrapping up that tweet about
how wonderful this conference is go
ahead and do that but then I suggest you
focus your attention on us and I really
appreciate it so basic
creative to frame this talk a very brief
history of monitoring's into about two
thousand five at Google we had a binary
they're called Boardman it's actually
it's in the book but you can think of it
as Prometheus in recent terms prometheus
is sort of an external recreation of
boardman it's a single binary collection
evaluation Clive monitoring system and
every team would run their own the core
binary and it has service scale but you
had to scale it manually you had to
arrange it in tears and like class up
aggregations to watch the global tier
and there was already sort of a movement
towards centralization so you'd have
some supporting infrastructure that
initially was per team but migrated to
be run by what then became production
monitoring a theory in about two
thousand seven or so that I'm now a part
of and this infrastructure including
things like metal monitoring so you want
to monitor that your board mods actually
work otherwise monitoring is kind of
useless you'd have long-term history
storage so you could serve queries over
multiple years and you would have the
alerting outbound part and in 2012 prod-
retook on monarch as the new
state-of-the-art monarch is a large
distributed monitoring system if you're
interested there's a great talk by one
of the monarch tl's john banning given
at monodrama 2016 you can find it online
it is google scale in one system so we
actually literally monitor all of google
in one monitoring system and it is
monitoring as a service in that as a
user you only have to provide a config
this still requires some knowledge right
I mean hence we're here giving talks but
it's much better than having to run your
own board months and this sketches to
secretary so in 2014 we acquired
stackdriver and I want to emphasize that
stackdriver is a natural evolution to
our cloud users it does not replace what
we've been using for years at Google so
instead of that it runs on top of
monarch and on top of our alert
management system and it uses the years
of experience of running services at
scale but stackdriver is geared solely
towards users of the cloud it was built
for monitoring cloud applications with a
focus on easy getting
started experience very user-friendly UI
and mantra which is still true today
which we strive to you don't have to be
an expert in monitoring to you monitor
your service as well so we prefer that
you focus your time and energy more on
innovation and less under the
administration's that was true when we
acquired stagger ever and it's true
today stackdriver has evolved to be more
than just monitoring so it offers a wide
range of other services and it supports
not just gcp but also AWS i'll cover
that more towards on the end of our talk
so now let's go over some definitions
and so we're sure that we're all kind of
speaking the same language so these are
commonly used terms in monitoring and
alerting sometimes they're overloaded
especially the alerting part so when we
talk about monitoring we're talking
about you know measuring performance
correctness observing building
instrumentation so that's really
extraction of metrics from our
application from our services into
something useful that we can use for
dashboarding and for alerting logging is
another type of information extraction
logs are a little different than regular
metrics in the sense that they're
immutable they have a timestamp but they
can also serve for monitoring for
example extracting metrics from logs
putting them in dashboards are learning
on them etc etc alerting again probably
the most overloaded term and it can be a
verb and a noun so alerting is the
process of also configuring your alert
rules and you know maintaining them it's
also the process of detecting issues
opening incidents and informing is some
sort sometimes also called alerting so
the act of informing users that are you
know you that something is wrong with
the services that you're running then we
have V bugging or figuring out the root
cause that happens usually after
learning it's getting down to the
problem it's mitigating the problems and
at the end when all is well again we we
sometimes do post-mortems kind of to
make sure that whatever happened does
not happen again or is treated more
efficiently user impact will be an
important term and we gave it its own
slide 43 definitions the SLA ino to
measure something like user impact s3's
especially set themselves service level
objectives so as an example you might
have an uptime objective for using up
time here is sort of a health check you
just issue an HTTP request and see if it
comes back of say three 9s right
ninety-nine point nine percent success
and for every SLO you would track the
corresponding indicator that's your SLI
which in this case is up time there's
another term SLA which is the actual
business agreement entered into with
customers the distinction between a and
O is kind of irrelevant to this talk so
we'll skip it one note here is if you if
you were aiming to go for like five
nines because you heard I don't know
Google does it or something be aware
with like everything you hear later you
only have five minutes per year for your
entire page response up to mitigation if
you actually have anything happen okay
so before we dive into the monitoring
philosophy and banks practices etc it's
very important to look at the process
around alerting a lot around monitoring
at a higher level so Thomas mentioned s
ellos we start by actually defining them
you have to realize what you want to
monitor before you start monitoring it
sounds trivial but we find that
sometimes people do it the other way so
you know think about what are yours
hellos what do you want to monitor what
do you want to put on dashboards what do
you wanna instrument you make sure you
get those metrics either from the system
that you're using the assistant level
metrics or custom metrics and then when
you have all that you can start actually
configuring your alerts so you know what
your alerting on everything all as well
and then an alert triggers so one thing
we want to emphasize with this diagram
is
you know this process is iterative
you're never really at a point where you
have the perfect configuration and
there's nothing more to do because
things change realizations change s
ellos change your service changes so
it's an iterative process but especially
in the beginning you should be prepared
to kind of change your alerting rules in
the way you're alert so if an alert
triggers usually an incident is open we
use that term to define like a problem
that somebody needs to take care of so
there's a time span an incident is
active and notification is being sent so
somebody is handling the the issue now
the first thing to figure out is if this
issue is real if it is real you need to
mitigate it you know debug maybe
escalate but if it's not real you need
to look at the alerting policy that
triggered rather than just going getting
back to work and not waste time the next
time it triggers and see what you need
to maybe change in the alert policy or
maybe delete when all said and done the
incident is resolved if it was real and
if it was you know serious enough maybe
a post-mortem is needed and we go back
to this this cycle of iterating on your
learning policies so now let's Segway
that you know we're done with the
definitions and we want to segue into a
little bit about monitoring what it is
and what drives good monitoring so why
do we monitor right why you here why do
you use a monitoring solution so these
are kind of them probably the main use
cases we monitor because we want to
detect and analyze trends it could be
business metrics it could be serviced
metrics you know we want to see for
latency is trending up or training down
or some resources or training to
depletion I want to compare over time
for example if it's business metrics for
one knows car checkouts how do they
compare to the last season or the last
month if it's late and see how does
latency compared to our air ratio
compared to last week we build dashboard
so we use metrics to build dashboard so
we have an
Glantz introspection into our services
rather than having to go and do a lot of
work each time we want to get some
answers to basic questions of course we
use metrics for alerting which is you
know the main main topic this is this
discussion and we also debugging is not
part of monitoring but it's very
strongly tied into it we use sometimes
we instrument metrics that will help us
debug that will help us drill down we go
we'll go into that later sometimes
winstram and ask for its just for the
debug part just for the firefighting
part so it's important to mention that
so what you really want to make sure
you're monitoring this is what we call
the four golden signals and that's a
painting of the four horsemen so if you
want to make sure your service doesn't
get to our Magadan level you want to
make sure that you're monitoring these
things at least write the first two are
errors or a ratio and latency why are
these important this is kind of these
are kind of the outbound facing metrics
of your service this is how your users
view your service so if your latency is
bad or if you have too many errors
that's immediately reflected in the
quality of service that you provide the
other two traffic which is
self-explanatory in saturation which is
really the the level that your resources
are full or the level that you're
utilizing your resources you can look at
these as kind of the view of your
service towards the inside so this is
what your service if it was a person
this is what it would be seeing it
seeing the traffic and it seeing the
saturation internally and these two can
lead to error in email to errors or bad
experiences that will eventually reflect
on your users so you're measuring these
four signals but then there's a question
of how right then we have an important
distinction here which is the difference
between black box or probing and white
box monitoring and so black box is if
you if you monitor from the outside you
treating the system as a black box hence
the name the advantage here is its
independent in terms of failure modes at
least largely usually which makes it
more reliable and it's better for
alerting
one example I mean you might have an
uptime Jack again for a stateful system
you may want the stateful program you
may want to I don't know if a file
system you write a new file put some
content in read it back see if it comes
back and then delete it again to clean
up and the opposite is monitoring that
works in the cooperation of the system
which is great because you get a lot
more detail and you'll need that detail
to do the actual debugging but again the
failure modes may be tied and so you
usually don't want to rely on this for
alerting a good example of one thing you
could not possibly get from black box is
the the bottom example if you compare
the actual memory handed out by your
Yoram malik versus the memory given to
your process by the operating system
there's no way you can get that without
it being exported from your process
right so just to put this in context
with the monitoring solution that we
offer on just a show of hands how many
of you are familiar with stackdriver
great let's say eighty-three percent
that's good the ones that aren't you
should be but what the way we offer
these for example and stack driver which
would you know most of you should should
be familiar with is black box monitoring
is our uptime check seen you should be
using that you know to set up up damn
checks to set up alerts on these kind of
and use probes from the outside white
box monitoring so for example the system
level metrics that are provided for your
resources for example custom metrics
that you know you as users need to
instrument for example the logs that are
available via the stack very sweet all
that is white box monitoring we have two
slides here about sort of a pet peeve of
mine an FAQ with monitoring is what is
the difference between those two graphs
there traffic a monitor data system in
this case the difference is sampling
rate so I made artificial grass to show
the example but the left one has one
minute sampling rate and the right one
has one second sampling rate quickie and
if you have very short spikes on the
minute for example which happens
surprisingly often you will never see
them on a typical one minute sample
monitoring system and again one
is really typical one second has a
significant overhead in terms of like
how often you need to go talk to your
system how much it takes to store that
data and another one is if you look at
distributions Layton sees in particular
so for example axis here is latency if
you're just looking at the mean and
maybe I don't know mean plus Sigma's
you're already missing a lot then maybe
you heard about percent of my
percentiles are important but then the
distribution that motivated this slide I
look something like this this is from a
caching front end for for a storage
system and so the behavior see is the
very low latencies like sub 10
milliseconds is it akash it and the bump
at something like 600 milliseconds is if
it has to go talk to its back end and
this is exceedingly common and you will
fail to see it if you only look at
latencies at presenters excuse me and
this now gets us to the philosophy that
you've been waiting for and we have
three core points1 you should really be
alerting on symptoms using s ellos we
will have some something that you'll see
in a slide in a moment that we call this
one criterion it's really really good to
remember it and we have a human aspect
that we'll discuss so the first thing
this is a section by the way about
philosophy so we're going to talk about
the why and later we're going to show
some best practices on more on the how
but the philosophy around alerting on
symptoms this focuses you ask somebody
that's monitoring their services on the
things that really matter to your users
so by alerting only on symptoms or the
vast majority of your alerts related to
symptoms that makes for a that you're
not wasting time are meaningless alerts
that may be alerting on things that you
know you could avoid notification if I'm
in the first place and also it focuses
you on really being alerts being tied to
the quality of service that your users
are seeing the second part of our
philosophy is one metrics these are
metrics that you should put every
alerting policy through to make sure
that it's
valid assuming we have a finit budget of
time you don't want to be wasting time
on meaningless alerts so any alert that
doesn't pass these tests should be
candidate for removal the first one is
judgment an alert should require human
judgment otherwise why waste a person's
time and also it can really upset people
when they get frequently alerted and
they feel like you know they don't have
to think or do anything it's just you
don't have to use any judgment and that
causes turn it should be urgent either
right now or next business day because
again if something isn't urgent why are
you diverting focus from other more
important things to this if it can wait
for a week or even a month it should be
actionable this one should be clear but
I just I want to explain it it means
that there should be some action that
needs to be taken as a result of this
alert other than reading the alert
notification now it doesn't mean it
doesn't mean that you you can mitigate
the the problem take for example I mean
we know cloud providers there are always
failure free but let's say your cloud
provider has some sort of failure you
should still know about it even though
there's not much you can do except email
me and others and hey what's up but even
then you want to maybe explain to your
users what's going on or through your
page or through your Twitter page you
know react to that be on high alert
maybe later divert traffic etc etc so
that's an example or something is
actionable but it's not something that
you can do with fixing the service and
the last but not least definitely
necessary if it doesn't affect anything
users service business why alert on that
maybe there are other more efficient
ways the human aspect the most important
one we think is you have to consider the
stress budget every alert triggers a
stress response this is good right you
need this this adrenaline boost to deal
with the alert especially
you're getting it at the middle of the
night or something but it has a cost to
the human it's a very biological thing
and you need to make that budget last
and there are two basic ways you can do
this you can keep the frequency of
alerting down just the pure number or
you can make the human more confident
and thereby reduce the stress for the
individual alert and we call this
providing help because if you support
them in especially the very beginning of
the response if they're better trained
they're better documentation they will
experience less stress and this the
second aspect of humans is they're good
at pattern recognition and somewhat lazy
again nurseries or automate themselves
out of their jobs in alerts especially
this means that specifically for
actionable mostly and people who realize
that something is not actionable and
start ignoring it at least
subconsciously and today of the three
core points again symptom-based soo
alerts 1 and the human aspect and will
now try and develop some actual best
practices that follow from this first 4s
ellos how do you choose an SLO and this
is not necessarily an alerting thing but
it's very important because it's a start
of alerting you should really bound it
between what your service can support
and what your customers can support
right so the service gives you an upper
bound of of how much you can ask and if
you if you get that wrong you put the
SLO too tight your own colors will burn
out that's like the number one risk is
you get too many pages you people burn
out if if you get the lower bound wrong
then your customers will leave right so
you have to get it between those and
just as a side note and the three nines
of uptime as a necessary tenant also
means you have point one percent of
downtime you can use to break stuff take
risks do something so we want to augment
that are you all familiar with the fail
whale and Twitter early days and we
actually want to bring up this example
as a positive example you can't always
be a perfectionist and you can't always
meet SLO that leaves your users and
sometimes you have to make decisions and
business decisions such as not meeting
your s ellos because you're experiencing
growth and the size of the team and the
size of the new users you're getting
every day just too much to meet your s
ellos and that's fine as long as you
make a conscious decision say you know
what a lot of my users are going to be
seeing this or high latency or not being
able to log in because right now it's
all ons on deck focusing on growth but
it has to be of course in a controlled
manner and you have to know why you're
you know you're not meeting your solos
so let's look at a one example matrix so
we we talked about why but let's look at
you know take few examples for each for
each of the kind of four tests so first
of all judgment good good judgment is
when there's an SLO alert right you have
to determine where the problem is or
there's some roll out and you have to
determine if the release is good or
maybe you have to roll back the release
they have to make some judgment there
that example is where in automated
actions such as server restarts take
care of things and you still get alerted
on it even though you know the automated
action took care of things or when
something can it isn't but it can be
simply fixed with auto scaling if all
the scaling is doing its job you
shouldn't be alerted on it even if
resources are kind of being stressed
another test is urgent so definitely SLO
and security issues both are very very
urgent you should alert on all of them
but if you find yourself saying
something like well you know if this
doesn't doesn't get fixed doesn't
resolve itself in 12 hours then we'll
look at it that's a candidate to kind of
revisit the alert maybe again you're
you're you're wasting time there and
it's important the reason we're
emphasizing this is again you have a
limited budget for your on caller turn
so you want to spend that budget not get
to alert fatigue you want to spend it on
the right things versus of the wrong
things that don't pass this test so
another thing is actionable when you
need to determine if something needs
roll back when you need to determine if
you
have to if you meet the add capacity and
it's not automatically added a bad
example which is actually quite common
is alerting on cpu percentage even
though again auto scaling can handle it
so if auto scaling scales when your CPUs
are you know to stress you know you
don't need to alert on that or another
thing is when just issues go away so you
see this it alerted it was red now it's
green nobody looked at it and we go on
and it and it edit it costs time even
even if nobody handled that alert people
look at it and it does cost time and of
course necessary so if it affects users
impact service impacts business metrics
anything else is not necessary if it's
or if it's covered by other alerting
rules for example so you see these
alerts that fire with other alerts
together all the time so great
candidates for removal next on some best
practice examples of how to think about
symptoms so SLO czar a little bit more
obvious right you have uptime latency
errors or ratios but internal components
you sometimes also have to alert on them
right if you look at your internal
component and think of it as a service
that's servicing other internal
components then you can figure out what
are the s ellos of that component
towards its peers and what are kind of
the black box metrics that you want to
look at when you're looking at that
component for example if you take batch
jobs for example if they don't complete
on time something is happening in there
but that might affect other services and
eventually that will affect your users
so you do want to alert on that and
that's actually that is alerting on
symptoms we do concede that if you have
your SLO alerts sometimes there's one
more thing you really want to do and we
call these cliffs because because of how
they measure when the system fails
catastrophically as in drives itself off
of a cliff and the typical case here is
the resource alert right if you write
your user data to disk and you run out
of disks or disk quota or whatever
you're not going to space today and the
advantage of then having a ninety
percent disk usage say for example alert
which is a very typical thing to do it
gives you early warning the SLO alerts
would only fire once you've actually
exceeded your quota and things are
actually broken I want to call out the
distinction here if SLO alerts are over
paging you and it's hurting you you need
to go and device the SLO if a cliff
alert is not giving you good
signal-to-noise just delete it right
there's nothing else to adjust just
delete the alert so now we want to spend
the next few slides talking about the
human factor which is very important in
the alerting equation and really around
two main things one is you know what
what's called alerting fatigue or you
know alerting fluke frequency and you
know kind of alerting overload and it's
a big problem especially a service of
scale and the other is remembering that
at the other end of the alerting policy
that you configure today another person
completely different person might be
paged so how do we deal with that so
firstly with the frequency limits Thomas
what have we learned over the years so
every has a fairly firm guideline of
having to outages per 12 hour shift on
average at most you will note i said
outages if you have multiple pages
fighting for the same outage it
shouldn't be money right but it's
frequently hard to get it down to really
one unlike for every outage so we don't
insist on that it should be a few but
the two outages per 12 hour shifts are
important if you get significantly more
than this you'll have burnout this can
be at an actual individual level where
someone literally gets burnout I can be
at the team level where morale things
people leave and you will get sort of i
would call it quality decrease right
people don't consciously ignore alerts
but subconsciously they kind of no
longer have the bandwidth they do
shallow investigations to push more
times don't really root cause anything
you're never really fixing anything and
so you
never digging yourself out of that hole
you might have far fewer do I have to
say in a sort of second law of
thermodynamics sense this this never
happens because the number of pages only
increases unless you have an active
investment to decrease it but if this
were to happen right you might have this
considered two points one is handling
pages gives you a lot of practice with
the system it's sort of the most
hands-on thing you can do you can
compensate this you can do training
right that's not a problem but you need
to make an effort and you may also ask
yourself is the investment in having a 3
support warranted if they're not even
getting any pages and I have some
examples here I want to go in some
detail into the first one the alerts
cried wolf problem we had a subsystem of
Monarch Deadwood on average like once or
a couple times per week have have a
problem and the problem will go away
sometimes you would tweak a setting
sometimes you wouldn't eventually will
go away and that led to sort of this
conditioning that I mentioned Isis
subconscious you know this isn't really
a thing and eventually of course the
inevitable happens and we had a real
problem and it was unnoticed for a week
even though if you knew where to look
you could tell that it was a completely
catastrophic failure that system was not
making any progress with a batch
pipeline and of course like in
proportion to it being stuck in that
state for a week also that the magnitude
of the problem then increased and you
really want to avoid this you see this
pattern when people say the alert went
away by itself and then push back on it
the other two I think are somewhat
self-explanatory i just wanted to
mention i observed all of these
firsthand right and so all of this does
happen watch out for it so this is how
fatigued actually looks like this is a
screenshot from stackdriver the red
lines and dots at the top are alerting
incidents and this is the time spent
from 5am to 8am now you know how many of
you want to be looking at this at 8am
raise your hands
yeah and you have to go and figure out
which of these alerts are real and how
many issues you have and what to do with
them you know that's clearly too many at
8am you know you want to be drinking
coffee and reading the politics section
of the newspaper but not looking at this
so that's an example when we're done on
the first thing you do after after
getting a page you will especially fix
an SLO based page right it's probably
coming from a prober after what we told
you if in a simple case the program
might have some back-end so for
simplicity I put two you'll want to know
is the problem with one of those or is
it somewhere behind them so that they
uniformly get errors and we call this
drill down and it the drill down might
look something like these these two
graphs and we have on the next slide and
it tells you right if in the first case
you probably assume its own some
back-end in a second case clearly one of
the services responsible you just need
to hover over the line and restart that
guy I mentioned this because frequently
in a real example you will have a load
balancer in between and you need to
think about how you're going to do the
signal which backends you picked from
like how you you're extracting that from
the prober before the pages happen right
because otherwise you're blind and you
cannot drill down when you actually have
a natural evaluation so the other thing
you want to do to help the human is used
ash boards and use what we call the
occu- in stackdriver sometimes it's
called referred to as run books you want
to make sure that whoever responds
understands what the alert is about what
was violated what's the SLO understand
the subsystem what subsystem it you know
relates to you know in your service
where to go how to mitigate you have to
provide that especially you know up
front and in the past escalation now the
most common mistakes that are made are
around mitigation and escalation because
when somebody responds especially if
you're going to meet a high level of
nines
the tendency is to go and debug in six
but actually the first thing you want to
make sure is that the problem is
mitigated maybe it's already mitigated
but it's going to crash very soon or
maybe you have to do something about it
like rollback etc that's the first thing
you should do and then escalation
whoever is in charge of this should
provide clears collation pass and also
it's desirable to add you know
escalation timeline so people don't
spend too much time being stuck before
they you know refer to their colleagues
so that was kind of those last few
slides were about helping the human now
we go into another thing which is
notification methods you want to have
redundancy with your notification
methods and not rely on a single
alerting notification methods because
problems can occur at the sending end or
problems can occur at the receiving end
where you know the uncle is not able to
receive that type of notification so if
it's just m+ one on the right side you
have a you know stackdriver screenshot
it's very easy to add additional
notification channels the free tier
includes email and cloud console app so
we recommend you use both of them for
all your learning policies if you have
it if you want additional methods you
can use on call software like and
rotation software like Pedro duty you
can use chat applications a web hook or
SMS to add to that I want to call out
SMS here is an SRE not because it's
especially reliable it totally isn't but
it's the most independent from all the
others among these so if you pick three
methods I suggest you put SMS there
because it gives you an independence
from all of the other styles
simultaneously to some issue in the
system and we have an example of this
actually happening I mean it's really
embarrassing if your pager fails
especially if you're on prod monetary
and you're supposed to keep the page we
running we had an example where do to a
male loop where every outgoing page
would loop back through mail and come
become a new page and we delivered about
100 pages per second to a single person
you click and show the image at oh there
he is so I have to admit this is for a
different outage but that one was on a
similar scale and the poor guy actually
received a large number of pages what
happened was we in for the internal one
for the internal paging app we use an
app engine server back-end and we just
used up the entire quarter of that
back-end and so it became non functional
for Oliver Sri until someone managed to
intervene about I don't know two and
half hours in myself and I say he looks
happy for someone that received so we
got a t-shirt engineers are always happy
when they get you sure that's totally
worth it something that you might be
more familiar with because it was very
very public as the DNS outage of late
2016 many many prominent services went
down and you know even though our
services were still up and running a lot
of third parties were experiencing
failures so we got a lot of support
calls because users were relying on one
service that might have gone down or the
api's are not available or the email
gets straight limited so again very
important to have redundancy with you
know the way your your alerts are
getting delivered so here are some
additional best practices kind of each
each one each slide stands on its own
one thing is grouping so you want to
reduce your alerts especially similar
alerts that kind of policies will do the
same thing for a bunch of resources that
act in unison you want to group them
together into a single policy if it's
stackdriver you can use stackdriver
groups which is kind of you know a
concept that is inherent in the platform
but think about when when problems occur
you don't want to get paged a hundred
times you want one alerting policy to
fire and then you know know that it
relates to to you know a group of
resources one thing to note though and
remember is that if you're doing this
you have to have efficient drill down
mechanisms because in many cases when
that alert fires you will have to kind
of investigate and see which of the
resources of which components of the
group
misbehaving and you know that hundred
page storm that we saw earlier mouths
that might sound funny and that person
was mining after he got the t-shirt but
it does happen every year to even inside
of Google so you know be prepared for
that and be you know ahead of the curb
and you know how to act a hundred pages
that arrive simultaneously you do a lan
over so we have two more slides on
process just like some brief notes if
you organize an on-call rotation our
guideline in s3 is forever I mean that's
sort of quick response right twenty-four
seven coverage five minute response time
to to working on the problem being at
the laptop you want two times six people
in different time zones or or eight
people in the same time zone again this
is just a burnout problem they'll be on
call too much if you have fewer people
and open out there were time similar to
how you have then plus one notification
methods you should probably have n plus
1 people who get notified I don't know
the primary might be on the new york
subway they don't have any reception
there so we recommend you have a
secondary this could be someone from
some other rotation or someone on the
team and then if that still doesn't work
you escalate to the entire team because
you just need your panic mode I guess
and what's really works for us is having
I mean if you're doing weekly shift
anyways it makes a lot of sense having a
weekly on coal handoff meeting they
should only take that a no half an hour
and post-mortem process I mean you you
probably know that basic drill right one
thing to call out here is we generally
right post mortems when either the
outages and was announced widely even
internally or that would user impact but
this is somewhat circular because in the
other direction the saying goes you
should really announced widely
internally at least if you think you're
going to write a post mortem people
learn and develop some experience for
this and and one thing to remember in
the context of alerting is it's somewhat
tempting in a post mortem to draw us and
as an action item add an alert this
should not usually be your only action
item right it's it's justified to add an
alert if you could have detected a
problem sooner by having this alert but
you should still go and
the root cause and push more times that
say add an alert and nothing else or how
you get into a situation where you have
page overload so with all these best
practices we didn't say anything about
Google cloud platform yet and we didn't
include any plug so the best best
practice in my mind is that running
remember running monitoring yourself is
a lot of overhead and folks like Thomas
are hard for come to come by and they're
not free so the best thing to do is
actually let somebody else do your
monitoring additionally if you're
running your own monitoring you have to
make sure that it's running correctly
which is called meta monitoring
monitoring your monitoring instead
Google cloud platform does offer
stackdriver and as I mentioned it's more
than just monitoring it's an integrated
suite of products that includes
monitoring logging alerting
functionality trays debugging air
reporting and it's very very tightly
integrated so for example a log that you
ingest goes into the logging and you can
analyze it there but if that's an error
it can also trigger error reporting it
could also trigger an alert you can take
that log and extract metrics torment put
it in dashboards alert on these or you
know do whatever you want so the nice
thing about it is it's all integrated
out of the box great experience and
there's a free trial there's also a free
tier you know if you're not using it to
a large extent you could stay on the
free tier but even premium pricing is
very very competitive to our discussion
today it's also geared towards helping
you utilize your time better and
actually implement best practices around
alerting so does offer up time checks to
help you focus around SLO flp focus
around symptoms it offers multiple
notification methods and run books and
other kind of custom dashboards to help
the person that's responding respond
efficiently to you know to alert the
specifications it offers great drill
down components oh really you know we
take our experience here and we use it
when we're implementing these services
so let's see if we remember everything
if you have to remember just one slide
remember the one with a guy in the
teacher not just kidding remember this
this slide let's go quickly go over the
four golden signals you should be
monitoring them latency and traffic how
your service is viewed from the outside
and I sorry latency and errors are
services you'd from the outside traffic
and saturation how your service you know
looks from the outside inside one every
alert policy should be tested to meet
these criteria judgment every alert
should be urgent should be actionable
and definitely necessary you should be
alert being mostly if not entirely only
on symptoms and these akmal include s
loz and you can also alert on cliffs
that will you know induce symptoms don't
forget the human factor so limit alert
fatigue limit the amount of pages that
somebody can get in a shift building
debug ability building the ability to
mitigate and help the on-call or
mitigate and provide a clear escalation
path for when people get stuck more than
one notification method is the next
thing use email use the cloud console
app SMS whatever but use more than one
and lastly remember that the process is
iterative right so you have to respond
efficiently you have to configure your
alert alert sufficient you have to
mitigate and also post mortem even when
the problem is gone let's make things
efficient the next time around
[Music]
you